[Music]
cctv footage zooming in
on a bridge in seoul this woman looks
like she might be about to jump
off
[Music]
but in fact she's a scientist
and part of a team at the seoul
institute of technology
they're working on a new cctv system to
detect and prevent
suicide attempts using artificial
intelligence
a new system is needed urgently
according to the emergency services
in the past cctv has often led to
misreading or false alarms
due to natural environmental factors
such as vehicles or winds
we believe the new cctv will enable our
crews to detect the cases a bit faster
and help us head to a call more promptly
the research is developing the new ai
technology say it works by spotting
patterns in the behavior of those
who've previously tried to drown
themselves
it does this by analyzing data from
surveillance cameras
sensors and nearly 3000 video clips
the hope is that it will help the
rescuers to make the right decision
about whether someone is at risk
the ai based deep learning system can
detect real-time situations
and predict suicide attempts when it
predicts a suicide attempt it will
automatically alert the rescue team
based on artificial intelligence and the
team will decide
whether to dispatch or not based on the
observation
the head of the water rescue brigade
says the number of emergencies
surged by more than 30 last year
because of the pandemic
and that most of those jumping were
young people
so any help but especially intelligent
help is welcome
if it manages to avert such tragedies in
future
you